are some breaking news to tell you about
now and wash and Emergency Services say
at least 10 people have been killed in a
plane crash between Moscow the capital
and Saint Petersburg let's bring in
Daniel Hawkins in Moscow for more on
this Daniel what more are you hearing
about the spring crash
well details are coming in very uh thick
and fast here we have to really pick out
what's coming in from official sources
what we know so far is that a plane has
crashed that was an umbrella 600 private
jet that was coming in from Saint
Petersburg to Moscow it's crashed in
adviskaya region Witnesses report
hearing at least one explosion before
the crash reports in the Russian media
unconfirmed so far officially are saying
this aircraft could have been taken down
by air defense systems in networks
region now from the videos we're seeing
on social media that does appear to be
witnesses that have filmed this crash
that have filmed the plane coming down
some sort of trail of smoke coming from
the plane as it crashes to the ground
and is burning on the ground we
understand Emergency Services say around
14 people are dead in this crash there
are no survivors but more importantly
Ross aviatse which is the Russian
Aviation Authority has said that Evgeni
precaution the head of the Wagner PMC
Wagner private military company was
among those on board was at least listed
as among those people on board that is
being confirmed or rather written about
by multiple Russian media accounts as we
speak there is other information coming
in as well that the second plane also
allegedly belonging to Uganda
has turned around and is heading back to
Saint Petersburg now we don't know uh
who's on board that plane if that
information is concerned is confirmed
but that plane that has come down on the
Russian Aviation Authority is saying
officially that if Guinea pregosian was
listed among those 14 passengers on
board quite significant uh if this is
the case that yevgeni pagosian uh the
head of the Russian mercenary group the
Wagner group was on board this private
plane I imagine there's been no official
confirmation yet from Russian
authorities on this
yes there's no official confirmation
um that precaution uh was was physically
on board that plane some journalists
reporting they're in touch with his
press secretary who's refusing to
confirm that information the press
secretary allegedly saying she refuses
to believe this information that
information though that he was listed
among the passengers on board has come
from the Russian Aviation Authority and
certainly the eyewitness accounts the
videos we're seeing uh unable of course
to independently verify as this has
happened literally minutes ago do show
this plane coming down
with a trail some sort of Trail next to
it uh in the sky okay so if you're just
joining us Daniel just stay with us if
just to remind our viewers of this
breaking news out of Russia Uh Russian
Emergency Services saying that at least
14 people have been killed in a plane
crash between Moscow the Russian capital
in St Petersburg uh uh correspondent
Daniel telling us that this was a
private plane and some Russian news
agencies now saying that you have guinea
pregosian the head of the Russian Wagner
mercenary group was reportedly on board
This Plane unconfirmed as Daniel was
saying just remind our viewers Danielle
of Hui Evgeni pagosian is and and the
Bad Blood between him and the Kremlin
recently
will anybody following the news out of
Russia over the last three months now
wouldn't know precaution has hardly been
out of the media Spotlight during this
time you've got any progression uh was
once a very close Putin Ally he was
known as Putin's Chef because the
catering company he owned uh reportedly
provided catering services for the
Kremlin he built his business in
catering and various other uh business
ventures but he's primarily known of
course for founding PMC vagina Russia's
private military company which for many
years was working in the shadows with
officials denying any knowledge of its
existence any official confirmation that
private military company came to the
lion blood particularly during the
conflict in Ukraine uh fighting on the
front lines and proving itself as one of
Russia's if not Russia's most potent
organized and dangerous fighting force
taken under control the city of bakmut
this earlier this year that relationship
as you say turn to Bad Blood uh in June
when you're getting precaution
responding to allegations of a strike
against his Fighters the camps belonging
to his Fighters led a mutiny uh onto
Moscow capturing an army building in
rostov and very quickly taking over take
over that that Army HQ and moving on to
Moscow before very suddenly after
negotiations involving the Bella Russian
president lukashenko standing down now
after that there was a lot of
speculation what would happen to
progression he was investigated criminal
charges were leveled against him for
Mutiny they were subsequently dropped
his company then moved to Belarus and it
was just days ago I believe our viewers
can see on the screen there that he
filmed a video from Africa saying that
the operations of PMC Wagner would move
on to the African continent and would
serve Russia's interest there that video
came out just a day ago so this is uh a
major shock and if confirmed of course
Julie is significant a hugely
significant major breaking news and
of course we'll keep a close eye on all
of this for you and bring you the latest
with Daniel who's a correspondent in
Moscow Daniel Hawkins thank you a
reminder if you're just joining us of
this breaking news story out of Russia
at this hour a Business Jet has crashed
in Russia and killed at least 14 people
according to a Russian emergency
services and several news agencies and
in fact the Russian Aviation Authority
saying that the head of the Wagner
mercenary group Evgeni fagosian was on
the passenger list unconfirmed yet
whether or not he has been killed but
they are saying that he was on the
passenger list this was a private plane
which was headed from Moscow to St
Petersburg I understand and evgeny
pregosian was said to be on the on the
plane itself not confirmed once again by
Russian authorities Daniel Hawkins is
live with us from Moscow Daniel they was
obviously after this you know the uh
Mutiny by progosian
there had been some dealers you
mentioned negotiated with Belarus and he
had been in Belarus in fact for some
time uh any information as to why he
would have been back in Russia
well despite the very serious charges
leveled against giving precaution
following this Mutiny um he didn't
suffer any any consequences the criminal
charges against him were dropped in a
very surprised move by the Russian
prosecution he was in fact seen at the
Saint Petersburg Forum photos appeared
of him in the in the Russian media
meeting uh guests from from Africa at
that Media Forum there are also photos
circulating in Russian media of him in
Russia following Matt Mutiny so despite
the um the initial information that he
would be sent to Belarus into effect of
Exile according to the Russian media
reports that simply wasn't the case he
had free movement he attended forums he
met uh people uh delegates from Africa
with which Wagner signed various deals
to provide security services for so it's
clear that his dealings whatever they
were in Russia hadn't come to an end
um what's interesting is the location
this plane has also crashed the Russian
air defense is a particularly active to
the east of Moscow in the areas of
belgorot those sort of areas on on the
borders which often suffer drone attacks
as a result of this Ukrainian conflict
the chances of a plane being shot down
by accident by air defenses in the
telescaya region which is way way north
of Moscow and not a region that's
commonly targeted by drones or shelling
is extremely unlikely that that such a
thing could have happened by accident
that again we're just speculating here
we're sort of providing some uh some
analysis but this wasn't the region that
was prone to conflict or any sort of
drone attacks all right we're
speculating uh of course as we said we
have to be careful about that but uh as
you know as you read social media right
now uh the speculation is that he was
eliminated uh evgoni pragosian
um
and of course I mean all
all eyes are going to be on the Kremlin
on this
foreign
yes we're going to be waiting for a
response um of course from the Kremlin
we understand the governor of touristar
region has taken under personal control
um this uh this incident
um this investigation into this crash
and again we have to stress at this
point it's not been confirmed that
progression was physically aboard it has
been confirmed he was in the passenger
list and there is information also
coming through just over the past few
minutes that Dimitri odkin
who was precautions effectively
right-hand man is Deputy commander in
PNC Wagner was also listed as a
passenger again no confirmation that
he's physically or was physically on
that yet but was listed among those
names we understand also from the the
flight tracking website a second jet was
also in the air that's turned around and
gone back to Saint Petersburg we don't
know who was on that jet we don't have
access to the passenger lists as of yet
but we understand a second plane has
turned around and returning to Saint
Petersburg and will be to see who was in
the lists on that jet obviously as well
okay Daniel we'll leave it there for now
and of course we'll come back to you
when there is new information again no
confirmation that you have any pregosian
was on this plane that went down between
Moscow and Saint Petersburg that crashed
between Moscow and Saint Petersburg but
at least 14 people killed however his
name was on the passenger list says
Daniel mentioned there we'll bring you
the latest on the story as and when
information becomes available